we know this you can walk outside
without a mask and then if you vaccinate
you can walk out anywhere
and you know inside you really are
vaccinated you can't transfer the virus
if you're vaccinated you can go anywhere
even yankee and mec games are starting
to say if you're vaccinated you can sit
next to each other
you know i'm sure it's going to be the
same thing with the nba in playoffs they
need their ticket revenue there's no
reason
to keep them out so the cdc who's all
over the place and we know now pressure
from politicians and pressure
and pressure from unions dr richelle
wilinski
put out some ridiculous guidelines for
camp goers that means so much to kids in
their development who've been
uh forced to sacrifice so much because
they do in their life their lives are on
at least a portion of it's on zoom
here's what dr rachelle wielinski saying
mask
everywhere except for eating you even
have to wear it
sleeping and you're participating in
outdoor sports in 100 degree weather
wear the mask cut 10. what we're really
trying to avoid in this camp guidance is
what we saw in outbreaks and camps last
summer so if you have
five ten-year-olds who are on a soccer
field all in front of the same soccer
ball we're trying to make sure that
they're not a lot of
heavy breathing around a singular soccer
ball with five kids around it at the
same time
but for spread out activities um our
outdoor mass guidance for unvaccinated
people
small groups allows for those kids to be
unvaccinated and
what we really are trying to do is
ensure that all these kids can have a
really good camp experience and keep the
camps open without any outbreaks
don't worry about the outbreaks the kids
aren't going to be affected
you want to do testing you go do texting
they're going to be fine
it's infinitesimal chance of a kid being
hospitalized
of course there's always a chance of
getting some something going wrong in
camp people for kids fall off cliffs
they get in fights some
there's like a ridiculous number of kids
drown i don't want any of that to happen
but it happens
and there's a greater chance of that
happening and parents are still dropping
off their kids
every single year from the beginning of
time but the restrictions are ridiculous
cut 11.
for the most part if you're vaccinated
we have recommended that you can do
almost anything we're asking that people
who are vaccinated remain
remain in masks when they're indoors if
i'm working with everyone in my office
is also vaccinated
why in our private settings guidance we
say if you know
for certain that everyone around you has
been vaccinated they're not at risk of
they have no
high-risk people in their in their
households then we say in those settings
that you could take off your mask
it's nuts because we were already told
by her
there's almost no chance of carrying the
virus once you're vaccinated giving it
to some other people
she tells everyone public health
officials recommend that campers and
people
be split into cohorts try to stay with
people you know listen to what they tell
these kids
split into cohorts okay cohort so i have
one friend
and we maintain you can maintain three
feet from that friend
between other children not non-cohorts
six feet ridiculous we already found
that that dates back to 1918 not even
debated on science
we've been through this already campers
are to remain six feet apart requiring
mass to be worn at all times
with exception of eating and swimming
the cdc expects campers to wear mass
while playing sports outside and
strongly discourages inside
or outside contact sports you know
everybody's playing football right
why can't they do it in camp do you know
they just finished spring football up
and down the northeast you know down
south they never even
delayed it for the most part they just
played football
now you're telling camps in 2021 kids in
2021
parents in 2021 don't let your kid do
all those things
it's insane and it's part of the reason
why in utah
at a pa a parent teacher and kid meeting
a local school board meeting
with it was packed they want to know if
the governor said we can get rid of the
mass mandate
why are you making our kids wear masks
listen to how out of control
this gets and just know uh i think
everybody i know feels the same exact
way as these utah parents
who let a state senator speak but didn't
let the parents and kids speak
cut 13. you let a senator come up here
and speak
in the name of my children who you guys
are abusing
are you serious you will listen to us
nope we've had our citizen participation
i know that we'll join this meeting i'll
second
[Music]
people i i mean don't they don't they
really represent some of the people that
you know
and how you feel in utah which by the
way they say is
accepting more people into their state
than maybe anyone else outside
florida utah for the most part utah is a
very calm place but when you have state
officials ruining your kids lives that
gets a little off the hook
so i want to let you hear from dr peter
mccullough he's watching what's going on
in this country he was on laura ingram
last night
and he says why is everyone so focused
on masks and vaccines
it's off-putting cut 16. now the overall
approach to the pandemic i think has
been way too much focused
on masks and vaccines neither one of
those helped sick patients
with coveted 19. that's plain defense
and in my view
the big change was when we had the
senate hearings in november
we started playing offense yeah
and we are on offense and vaccines are
up there 44 have gotten a single shot
33 percent are fully vaccinated we know
that hospitalizations are down 11
deaths are down 3 percent overall cases
are down 27 percent
so listen to a mark gorilla he said this
from columbia university
told new york magazine about all these
restrictions
i am supportive of effective measures to
restrain the spread of the ill
illness however the cdc's
recommendations crossed the line into
excess
and are frankly senseless children
cannot be running around outside in 90
degree weather wearing a mask period
quote masking kids at camp outdoors is
simply virtue signaling
requiring kids to continuously wear
masks at camps
even while outside playing in the heat
when it provides little additional
protection
is unfair and cruel to children a doctor
in the national institute of algae and
infectious disease said who would remain
nameless
even dr fauci said they're a little
extreme
i went to brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now